elle n'avait bonjour alors quelle est
l'atmosphère sur place
écoutez olivier pour l'instant cette
manifestation se déroule dans une
ambiance plutôt correct en a plusieurs
centaines de manifestants et bien qu'ils
scandent des slogans hostiles à la
police police française police
américaine puisque pour eux c'est la
même chose que ce soit ici ou outre
atlantique
ces manifestants aujourd'hui dénonce le
racisme et les violences policières et
ils sont elles ont fait le déplacement
aujourd'hui place de la concorde pour
rendre hommage à georges la faillite cet
américain de 46 ans qui a été tué lors
d'une intervention policière et à toutes
les autres victimes
ici en france puisque il estime que les
violences policières ne s'arrête pas aux
frontières américaines alors ici en
france et le rende hommage d'arrêt damas
traoré à cédric chou via ou encore à
mohamed agassi et voilà donc une
ambiance plutôt cordiale même si on a
constaté quelques tensions au moment où
les forces de l'ordre ont débarqué avec
leur camion canons à eau mais voilà on a
plusieurs centaines de manifestants et
cie qui est bien profite de l'occasion
pour bien protester contre le racisme et
les violences policières je vous propose
justement d'écouter quelques
manifestants
en fait moi je me dis que le prix par de
france étudie mais en fait ici en france
n'a pas les mêmes soucis comme aux états
unis
moi j'ai dit moi en fait on contraire
s'il n'y a pas de soucis pourquoi il ya
autant de gens ici en train de
manifester ça veut dire que vraiment il
a un souci
il est en suisse aussi ici comme comme
aux états unis qu'il allégeant ainsi
qu'il souffre qu'il ya un système qui
était créée est sympa qu aux etats unis
c'est partout ce partout dans le monde
de ceux ci s'y associer en france aux
états unis ça brésil c'est à columbia
sont cuba sont en afrique sont affichées
ici c'est vraiment c'est partout c'est
important de montrer une certaine
solidarité avec les manifestations à
travers le monde
je pense qu'il faut montrer aux pouvoirs
publics qui tient qu'un cas qu'un
changement qui s'impose
finalement on a l'impression qu'on est
dans un point tournant et on espère
qu'on pourra saisir cette opportunité
pour faire des changements permanents
pour les générations futures
on le rappelle cette manifestation ici
un personnage et ses interdite par la
préfecture de police qui est bien craint
un débordement des troubles à l'ordre
public et puis une manifestation
interdite puisque le décret du 31 mai
2020 et bien proscrit tout rassemblement
de plus de dix personnes dont deux voix
l'une rassemblement qui s'est déroulé
dans la bonne humeur
merci nadège pour ces précisions à
nadège abderrazak en direct de la place
de la concorde à paris et merci à lionel
girard pour les images